possibly the concept most crucial to
general relativity is that of the metric
tensor
the 10 numbers which
assigned to every point of space and
time
rule our modern physics
but despite the importance of this
concept it's hard to find an explanation
of it beyond just merely superficial
mathematical definitions
is there a better way we can understand
its significance
[Music]
and what does it ultimately reveal about
the nature of our reality
this is dialect and today we begin
exploring
the meaning of the metric tensor
general relativity is so buried under
mind-bending ideas and esoteric
mathematics that the basic secret of the
theory might easily escape your notice
all you're doing in general relativity
is making a map
a map of space and time
that's it
you are literally
a space-time cartographer
when european seafarers and navigators
realized that the world was round
they needed a way to depict a spherical
surface on a flat piece of paper that
they could hold in their hands
that is
they had to take a two-dimensional
curved surface and map it onto a
two-dimensional flat surface
similarly when physicists discovered our
four dimensions of reality were not flat
but formed a single curved totality
they needed a way to depict a
four-dimensional curved surface
using only the resources allotted to a
casual observer
i.e the four independent measurements of
space and time
meaning they had to take a
four-dimensional curved surface and map
it onto a four-dimensional flat surface
now over the centuries cartographers
have developed many different types of
map projections
there's the mercator
robinson
goods
the azimuthal equidistant
etc
all of these maps depict the curved
totality of the earth in different ways
and while no single map encompasses the
entire earth accurately
each offers its own advantages according
to the various nautical geographical or
political needs of its user
similarly
physicists have developed many different
maps of space-time
these are referred to as coordinate
systems or coordinate charts
we have schwarzschild coordinates
kruskal chakras coordinates
flrw coordinates
etc
just as with maps of the earth
no single coordinate system can
encompass the entirety of a space-time
region
while accurately preserving
proper distances and proper times
but each can highlight or emphasize
particular qualitative features about
that space-time region which may or may
not be useful to the physicist
now every good map needs a bar scale
and as we discussed in our prior video
a metric is simply just that
a bar scale
or the mathematical object which tells
us how distances on our map translate to
distances in the real world
in the case of our space time map it
tells us how coordinate distances and
coordinate times
translate to proper distances and proper
times across different locations of our
map
now you're probably used to a map having
only one bar scale
but a map of something like the earth
actually requires a bar scale at every
single point
since distances and areas everywhere are
continuously being distorted
on this robinson map for instance
a centimeter interval across greenland
does not represent the same distance as
a centimeter interval
across equatorial africa
similarly on our map of spacetime
we'll need a metric or bar scale at
every single space-time point to
indicate how our space-time distance is
changing across the map
this comparison is important so we're
going to reiterate it
on a regular map a metric takes us from
physical distances on the map to
physical distances on the earth at each
and every point
while on a space-time map the metric
takes us from coordinate distances on
the map to space-time distances on the
space-time manifold at each and every
point
but what is space-time distance exactly
well it's more properly termed the
space-time interval
and it corresponds to the amount of time
that would elapse on a clock
located at a particular space-time point
as measured by an observer also located
there
so essentially our space-time metric
tells us how fast or slow clocks all
across the universe are ticking with
respect to our map user's local
reference clock
but since the space-time interval
contains information not just about how
time is changing across the map
but also about how space is changing too
if you want to keep all this information
separate you're gonna need more than
just one number at each point on your
map
in fact you're gonna need 10 numbers at
each point
and this is where the tensor part comes
in
how exactly
well in our last video we explored the
basic topological procedure for going
from a curved surface to a flat surface
or vice versa
basically you cut your surface or
manifold into many small nearly flat
pieces
then you stretch and or skew each piece
before rearranging all the pieces into a
new surface
because this process takes a distance
element that is a right triangle
and turns it into a distance element
that is an acute or obtuse triangle
your distance goes from being described
by the pythagorean theorem
to being described by the law of cosines
or one of its higher dimensional analogs
the components of the metric tensor
are then just the various lengths and
cosines of angles needed to determine
the length of your new distance element
as an example of this overall process
let's take a look at an equirectangular
projection of the earth
this projection takes the earth's lines
of latitude and longitude and gives them
equal spacing on a flat map
thus forming a standard cartesian
coordinate grid
let's designate our axes by the
variables x and y
the values of y range from 0 to pi and
the values of x range from 0 to 2 pi
okay now that we have our flat surface
let's follow the basic topological
procedure for transforming it into a
curved surface
first let's cut the map into many tiny
squares
next let's impose the following metric
on each square
this metric
or more precisely the metric tensor
which we are assigning to each tiny
square piece
has three numbers or components
the first component tells us
by what amount to stretch or shrink the
x length of the piece
the value of this component is the sine
of the value corresponding to the
y-coordinate of that piece
so this tells us that the x-length of
pieces near the equator where the sine
of the y-coordinate value is equal to
nearly 1
will not be stretched or shrunk
whereas the x-length of pieces near the
poles or the sine of the y-coordinate is
equal to nearly zero will be shrunk to
close to zero
meanwhile the x lengths of all the
pieces in between will be shrunk an
intermediate amount
now
the second component tells us how much
to stretch or shrink the y length of the
piece
here everywhere on the map that
component is equal to one so this tells
us that the y length of all our pieces
remains unchanged
finally our third number or component is
zero
this tells us that the cosine of the new
angle between our transformed axes
should be zero
the cosine of 90 degrees is zero
and since the old angle between the axes
of our pieces was already 90 degrees
this means there will be no skewing of
any of our pieces across the map
we see we now have all the correctly
sized pieces of a new surface
with a little more information about the
coordinate transformation
we can rearrange our pieces into a new
surface
[Music]
notice that there are some gaps between
pieces as well as some places where the
pieces overlap and are touching
which we see especially towards the
poles
this is because we did not cut our map
into small enough pieces
but the theory of differential geometry
assures us that if our pieces were
infinitesimally sized the surface of the
sphere will approach its proper shape
and area
now rather than an equirectangular
projection
if you instead started with a projection
like the robinson one where the lines of
latitude and longitude didn't intersect
at right angles
you would end up with the third
component in your metric tensor being
non-zero
this would indicate that
in addition to needing to be stretched
or shrunk
pieces across the map would need to also
be skewed before being rearranged into
their new surface
zooming into this spot in north america
for instance we see that the angle
between the lines of latitude and
longitude here is about 45 degrees
the tiny square patch which resides
there then would have to be skewed until
the proper angle of 90 degrees between
the lines of longitude and latitude was
reached
thus the original coordinate angle
between the x and y axes on your patch
which was 90 degrees
would get stretched to a value greater
than 90 degrees
and it's the cosine of that angle which
essentially gives you the value of your
third metric component
with the caveat that it has to be
multiplied by the magnitude of the other
two components first
all right we've mastered the
two-dimensional metric
so let's take it to the next level and
look at a three-dimensional metric
now as with our two-dimensional case
we're going to start out with a flat
surface for a map which in three
dimensions is just your conventional
euclidean 3d space
previously we cut our map into many tiny
squares
now we'll cut our map into many tiny
infinitesimally sized cubes
dx by dy by dz
then we'll assign a metric tensor to
each infinitesimal cube on the map
okay let's zoom in on a particular cube
in three dimensions the metric tensor
has six components
three for the three sides of the cube
plus another three for the three angles
between pairs of axes
these components at any point will be a
function of the map coordinates
since again our bar scale is changing
across different points of the map
so let's just say that those functions
at this specific point where our cube of
interest is located end up giving us
something like these numbers
now the first instruction from the
metric tensor at this point
is to multiply dx by 1.5
the second instruction is to multiply d
y
by three-fifths
the third instruction is to multiply dz
by four-fifths
next the fourth instruction is to take
the angle between the x and y axes and
shrink it until it equals 70 degrees
similarly the fifth and sixth
instructions tell us to make the angle
between the x and z axes equal to eighty
degrees
and the angle between the y and z axes
equal to 60 degrees
we now have the correctly sized piece
that belongs to our new curved manifold
moving to the next point in our
three-dimensional map we read the new
metric tensor instructions there to size
that piece as well
repeating this for every point in our 3d
map
we arrive at a collection of properly
sized pieces for our new manifold
now
were we in possession of a higher
dimensional coordinate transformation we
could conjoin these pieces
into a curved entirety like we did with
the earth
[Music]
however
there's a problem with this
the problem isn't that we can't imagine
more than three dimensions
rather it's that we may simply not be in
possession of a higher dimensional
coordinate transformation to begin with
and backwards deducing one may not be
possible or physically meaningful
at any rate if our map is equipped with
a metric tensor field we will at least
have an understanding of how the
manifold looks locally at every point
well that's it
you're just steps away from taking the
metric tensor into the four dimensions
of space-time
and beginning to really understand how
general relativity works
but we're out of time for today
so we'll continue our exploration of the
meaning of the metric tensor in a future
video
so stay tuned
this has been dialect thanks for
watching
you